[Music]
next up terrorism how do we talk about
terrorism in his column last week rod
little said that there is a certain
madness in the way the media discusses
terrorist acts after they have happened
depending on what the killer is or who
the killer is
peter hitchins on the spectator online
this week took great exception to rod's
column he wants us to focus on mental
illness and particularly on drug-induced
psychosis
peter what was it about what rod said
that you took such great exception to
well i think the thing that i didn't
like was these
particularly was that he said that
nobody had said at the time of the
murder of joe cox
that mayor the killer was
was actually crazy
and i had actually gone to some lengths
to point out that this was very much the
case and it got in quite a bit of
trouble from left-wing persons for
saying so
and i think that it was an important uh
an important point of disagreement
because so much
of the discussion about these events
is prejudiced by the desire of various
people in america
gun control liberals in this country
conservatives who see islam as a major
problem uh and among the guardian
reading left in this country people who
believe that there's a huge right-wing
extremist problem in this country they
all want to believe that these events
are fundamentally political and or
religious
my view of looking at very many of them
is that the
the real fundamental problem the thing
which has changed in our society most of
all in the past 50 years is the huge
number of people who are taking various
kinds of legal or illegal mind-altering
drugs and the terrible effect which this
has on them and i think that's the thing
which these events have in common and
what i really want to see is an inquiry
into every act of violence especially
lethal violence into the the drug taking
backgrounds of the culprits because i
think it would it would it would uncover
something quite startling to those who
think this is fundamentally political
and i thought that the the dismissal of
the of the idea that uh
the mayor was actually really just off
his head uh was wrong rod do you think
uh in your eagerness perhaps to uh pin
the blame on islamism you're overlooking
the fact that all these people are just
mad and possibly mad because of drugs
i don't know that's exactly what i said
i don't think the problem's islamism uh
uh primarily um what i was trying to do
was change out the nuances between what
constitutes madness and what constitutes
badness if you like and incidentally
when i use the word nobody says uh as
peter quoted me of saying i i mean in a
slightly different sense to how most
people really i mean nobody except for
peter me and melanie phillips
um
so it's a good
nobody isn't quite the finite term it is
when the ordinary people use it but i i
take peter's point um
and and i was nudging towards
that suggestion which that
uh that
uh every single block of society has
agency when a tragedy occurs and tries
to insist that it is the consequence of
people they don't like doing it and the
thing which i found most fascinating was
anders bredvik in
norway
where initially of course the
psychiatrist found him mad as a hatter
which is a
a derogation i would probably go along
with having looked at the case in fall
though not having examined him
but then this was overturned
simply
or primarily
because the left wished to insist
that the
the racist politics espoused by anders
brevitt inevitably led to that kind of
carnage
uh and that therefore
uh it wasn't the case that he was insane
whereas clearly
as one of the psychiatrists put it i
would
suggest that he was insane simply by
dint of the fact that
as his psychiatrist put it
his politics came along to provide a
space for his
psychotic behavior rather than the other
way around
it's a problem partly uh rod that i mean
our definition of mental illness now is
so broad it ranges from everything from
uh schizophrenic psychosis to just
feeling a bit down
that actually nobody can talk sensibly
about madness and and what drives mad
people to kill people
that's certainly true that's certainly
true and we've also
uh uh gone along a bit of the path that
norway has gone along with which is to
kind of
exonerate mental illness to the degree
that it is something which affects
someone and that therefore the person
cannot possibly be responsible
now we have a
slight backlash in this country with
some very eminent people i think
i think it's paul morales at leeds
university uh who are positing a
post-liberal
study of insanity and suggesting that
for example
whilst mental health
charities will tell you that there is
nothing to be feared from schizophrenia
uh
paul morale and others suggest oh yes
there is and the public is absolutely
right to stay the hell away from
so there is that
and yes of course we talk far too much
about mental health none of this
incidentally
because it's something i didn't touch on
at all which is probably by why peter
reacted none of this
should uh uh prejudice one way or the
other peter's excellent thesis that it's
uh drugs which are primarily to blame it
could well be in many cases so not i
think in anders prefix case well this is
the problem you see you you don't even
know that ernest breivik was a user of
steroids uh
it's so i knew he used steroids but but
but but well this is if you're if you're
suggesting that every single
uh pharmaceutical uh pertinence uh is
it could be a contributory factor in in
uh acts of extreme violence no i'm not
saying you're stretching the net a
little wider but that's that's a great
whopping great straw man what i've
what i'm pointing out is that the there
has been absolutely zero interest
anywhere in the fact that bravo used
steroids uh but if you look at a number
of these crimes omar martin the orlando
the orlando killer
or you you look at the london bridge
killers uh or you look at brenton
tarrant the man who responsible for the
mosque massacre in christchurch in new
zealand they're all steroid users so
it's not the argue all you often get
from people who say oh well are you
saying everybody who smokes a joint is a
killer or everybody who takes
antidepressants is a killer or everybody
who takes steroids as a killer now i'm
not saying that
what i am saying is that if you come
across people who have crossed this
extraordinarily uh well patrolled
boundary uh that that keeps most of us
uh from attacking our fellow creatures
with guns knives or bombs and have
actually done it the one thing they tend
to have in common
is that they have taken powerful
mind-altering drugs we don't know how
much we don't know how how long they've
done it for the reason we don't know any
of this is because nobody cares quite
often i look at crimes which are totally
irrational and i i go to the police
forces involved officers and say could
you tell me did you investigate uh the
culprits drug use
and after i've taken them in many cases
the information commissioner it emerges
they haven't even asked they're not
interested there is a fundamental lack
of interest in our criminal justice
system in this very very important point
they don't look they're not interested
they don't ask they don't care i should
think uh probably 99 of people who have
heard of anders breivik have no idea uh
that he took steroids and in fact his
revolting testament in which he makes
this plane uh is now almost unobtainable
uh so you can't even read it to see but
that's where it is but in so many cases
uh whether whether in the
terrifying number of school and college
shootings in the united states uh or in
the the the people who drive vehicles
into crowds uh on both sides of the
atlantic uh you will find over and over
again if you look and if there's been
any attempt to find out you will find
that the use of some sort of powerful
psychotropic is present so i can draw no
conclusions from this because the
evidence is is still too thin but i
think it's incredibly irresponsible of
our societies to put these to one side
say oh it's because there's no gun
control oh it's because of islamism or
oh it's because he was simply mad and
there's no explanation for it rather
than actually setting up what we need
which is a proper inquiry into the role
of these drugs this is new these things
are not have not gone on throughout
human history uh they've begun to take
place really in only since the 1960s and
they are becoming increasingly common
and if we don't find a proper
explanation for them we will not stop
them and we will live with more and more
of them and that's what i get sick of is
the immediate placing of these things
into into political categories which
suit the politics of the person who make
it rather than into
an intelligent inquiry into what's
really going on
but the drugs aside that's exactly what
i was arguing about
well you can't put the drugs aside can
you in that argument the drugs are
absolutely central to that because they
are the big they're the big change
just a second i mean what i was
objecting to was that immediate
categorization by both right and left
and
and to center indeed for that matter
uh uh uh it's it's it's a it's a
function of our times it's a function of
the internet but
remi remind me what were you saying
about the bow and arrow uh the bow and
arrow event in norway
what was i saying about that yeah what
was your view of that what were you
thinking like what were you what were
you what were you turning towards well
again they did exactly the opposite with
the bow and arrow what interested me
about that was the fact that the
authorities did the exact reverse of
what they did in the case of anders
brevik which was at first say this is a
terrorist attack and ascribed to blame
to uh uh to the guy's islamic beliefs
islamist beliefs
and then uh uh
within the space of only about seven
days uh changed completely and said no
it's nothing to do with islamism it's to
do with his mental health uh he's been
uh on antidepressants he's he's had uh
various psychotic episodes etc etc etc
and they ditched islam all together from
it uh so i mean what do i think i don't
know because i haven't interviewed
anybody who's uh
[Music]
it
i'm sure he's right which is that this
is something which is never investigated
and i think the reason for that is the
year which uh peter cited earlier in
1960
uh and i think since 1960 our view of
drugs has changed
which is why we have many many more
addicts
uh many many more heroin addicts as well
as addicts of various other if you wish
to call them addicts i know there's a
there's a scientific difference between
addiction and uh and
habitual use
because society as a whole has decided
that drugs perhaps aren't quite as bad a
thing as we thought them to be 50 to 60
years ago and that colors the way in
which
we treat people who use drugs
and i would suggest that the current
leniency in the courts towards drugs is
also
a symptom of that and so so to that
degree i agree with peter
well in that case surely we need to
revise our relaxation of our views on
drugs if if the damage that
that they're doing uh could be as great
as this it's time we stopped we stopped
taking the 1960s attitude
peter
you've been bravely banging the the drum
about cannabis induced psychosis for a
long time now and you're one of the very
few people
uh with a sort of public profile that
does it uh and yet uh the society is
going against you you know we are moving
more and more towards uh cannabis
legalization do you think you've lost
the fight oh certainly i've lost it uh
i've spent most of my life winning
debates and losing the vote
it's extraordinarily difficult to
persuade people
particularly to vote against something
which they think gives them pleasure
and
that that's just the case but the
problem with this will be that if we
ever do get to the point of legalized
marijuana advertised everywhere and
available in in high street shops and
freely on the internet and it turns out
that i'm right about the the correlation
between marijuana use and
mental illness
then it will be almost impossible to
undo the damage uh so i'd say now
just imagine me cackling from whatever
post-death location i find myself into
uh i told you so uh when you've made
this mistake i don't know what else i
could do
honestly
than what i have done to point out this
danger and also to point out how
irreversible the legalization of drugs
is i have to keep saying don't do this
stupid thing i have to keep saying yeah
sure sure but and i agree with you but
well i haven't seen i haven't seen your
piece demanding that the the um the laws
against marijuana possession
should be
i have written about that and i've
written uh i've written about our
attitudes towards drugs in general not
from the point of view of inducing
psychosis in individuals which lead to
the sort of killings you're talking of
but in the general form that
it is another factor
of
what has come out of the mid 60s partly
the mid 60s partly probably also the 80s
and uh
the chicago school of economics partly
the frankfurt school of sociology in the
60s that that we uh that is it's all
about self-actualization
and uh in short we should be allowed to
do whatever the hell we like
and tied in with that
drugs is obviously a huge problem
debt is a huge problem uh we had very
little debt you know back in the in the
early 1960s uh there was very little
personal debt
uh but also marriage uh divorce children
the way we bring up children everything
has been geared to making us uh be able
to fulfill ourselves in what to fill out
boots with whatever the hell we want and
i think drugs is absolutely a part of
that and i think you're you're right
you're banging on the right track peter
i'm sure
[Music]
you